what's up gq i'm noah beck and today i'm
going undercover on the internet
it's actually me
cora
[Music]
would you consider being an internet
influencer a real job
could have asked me that
a year and a half ago i'd probably have
a different answer than i do now once i
started to really understand and talk to
some of the people that are in the
industry it is very much a real job and
people tend to clown on it a lot because
it doesn't take a lot of like
qualification and you're right i
understand where they're coming from
when they're working their ass off doing
nine to fives but it's very much a job
and it's very much a career path
who is noah beck dating noah beck is
dating dixie demilia i met her at the
hype house last summer we became really
really good friends and we became best
friends and then became more than
friends and the rest is history posted
what do you think of noah beck's nsfw
calvin klein photos
gonna be honest don't know what nsfw is
like
like you wouldn't be at work with your
laptop
oh
okay i really don't think much of this
shoot because like i dance shirtless on
take talk so like there's nothing people
haven't seen i just didn't have bottom
layers on to be honest replied
let's see some youtube comments
is no one going to talk about how he
said 100 he would start only fans
should i
probably won't be seeing that from me
anytime soon if you want to go back and
look at the calvin klein shoot you can i
think that's all you guys are gonna get
for a while
unless things totally go south replied
what is he up to now
a lot of fun things on the way you may
be seeing me on a bigger screen coming
up not only that you may be seeing me on
a field i may try to get back into
soccer we never know a lot of fun stuff
stay tuned
next
so you're telling me if kobe didn't
happen we wouldn't know who noah is that
very well may have been the case unless
you follow
soccer i just got lucky honestly that is
interesting to think about
all right moving on to twitter
[Music]
how did nobeck managed to make the front
cover of a high fashion magazine that's
a great question two question marks kind
of like makes me think that he's like
really curious and i almost feel
attacked yes i was on the cover of the
man very blessed to be in the position
that i'm in
noah beck has never drank damn what that
is correct i i've never drank well in
high school i would go out with my
friends and i would see them drink and i
would see how stupid they looked and i
told myself i do not want to look like
that to be honest i like kind of being
like the dad of the group and taking
care of everyone
all right moving on to instagram
on the scale of one to ten how much does
he miss dixie when i'm not with her it's
usually a ten unless she's annoying me
one day then it could go down she's my
best friend and just sucks when i'm not
with her always will miss her when we're
not together posted
is there anything you're not good at
i like to be humble humility is
something that my parents always try to
engrave into me hard work gets you a lot
of places just remember that my dad gave
me that hard work mindset for everything
i do in life posted
back to twitter noah beck has his own
reality show question mark exclamation
point
not exactly a reality show but i do have
my own show on awesomeness tv called
noahbeck tri-stings and i will be
filming season 2 very shortly so keep an
eye out for that i'm in a reality show
with the sway boys called sway life so
you can check that out as well and
yeah
what the [ __ ] is nobody going to bring
to the met gala or bryce hall like what
probably nothing because i don't think
i'm going to the met gala so don't have
to worry about me bringing anything
next
more cora
um
who is better bryce hall or noah beck
i don't know we're both good at
different things i think bryce is
definitely a better entertainer than i
am he's very good at what he does and i
think i'm good at what i do next
who is the all-time best footballer
this could get me in trouble cristiano
ronaldo to me is the best footballer of
all time but leno messi is
god-given my philosophy is that we stop
debating and just appreciate how great
they both are you know
how do you get famous on tick tock
it's a great question there's really no
magic formula to this find your niche
and
stick to it post consistently the
algorithm really notices that and tend
to push your videos when you post
consistently every single day i post
three to four times a day and the more
you post the more one is bound to do
better than the others you
know youtube
noah one of the beck boxes making a
comeback hopefully very soon as you guys
know i put together these back boxes
myself just in terms of like the
distribution and getting out to you guys
that's kind of like the tricky part
right now but we're working on it and i
promise you they will make a comeback
replied
if soccer was truly his passion then why
did he choose tick tock
honestly my only answer to this is
opportunities that couldn't be passed up
came about it was the hardest decision
i've ever had to make in my life if i
would have chose soccer i kept in touch
with like my friends on my college team
they didn't start back up training until
january so like i would have been
sitting at home and i'm super grateful
and blessed to be where i'm at in social
media replied
[Music]
can we talk about how impressive his
performance was at the end sometimes
players in the world cup can't even get
a penalty kick right whoever commented
this i love you but keep in mind that
this was edited and i can't hit this
every single time this did take multiple
tries thank you
yeah there is editing next
tick tock here we go these should be
interesting
what can your fans do to support you
slash make you smile y'all have done
enough honestly what can i do to make
you guys smile that's what i'm trying to
get out here posted
do you ever see yourself playing again
yes i do see myself playing again where
don't know when don't know i mean that
was my dream ever since i was three
years old and it's still my dream so
we'll see
all right gq that's it i'm signing off
the internet